[Music]
[Applause]
you often hear the phrase the bad
neighborhood is on the other side of the
railroad tracks but have you ever
wondered what came first the bad
neighborhood or the railroad tracks and
the answer is it's complicated it's
complicated because in the u.s. cities
have been strategically designed to
enable some people to succeed while
keeping others namely inner-city black
families from finding that same success
so what's the impact of this today it
means that the unemployment rate for
black individuals is nearly twice that
for white individuals and it means that
it would take a staggering 228 years for
the average black family to accumulate
the same amount of wealth the average
white family has today every time I hear
these statistics I cringe this is about
so much more than low socioeconomic
status this is about race so I began to
wonder how did we get here to understand
the problem we need to go way back it's
the 1920s in the start of the great
migration the migration and which more
than six million black individuals move
from rural areas of the south to cities
in the north and the West by coming
north they hope to escape the overt and
often violent racism of the Jim Crow
South but what they found was an even
more insidious form of racism in the
north
racism hidden in the structural makeup
of where they lived when black families
came to the north they were subject to
the threat of the double 8 housing and
highways in the 1930s the government
sponsored homeowners Loan Corporation
graded us neighborhoods to determine if
they would be approved for home loans
the form asked is this neighborhood
Negro yes or no and this was the number
one determinant
of whether a neighborhood was approved
for a home loan so in black families
tried to buy homes they were told again
and again home loans are not available
to you and so these predominantly black
neighborhoods were systematically denied
access to home loans in the u.s. not
being approved for a home loan is
essentially a sentence for poverty home
ownership accounts for more than 60% of
wealth accumulation and this only gets
worse over time as wealth or lack
thereof
is passed down generation after
generation but the problems didn't stop
at a lack of housing in 1956 President
Eisenhower unveiled his grand plan for
the u.s. interstate highway system for
urban planners the creation of a highway
was an easy way to take care of the
places and spaces of people of color
which they termed blight for Robert
Moses the master builder of New York
City purposely built the highway to cut
through the heart of the black community
and to isolate black neighborhoods from
the rest of the city with the creation
of the highway blacks whites fled to the
suburbs these new suburban families no
longer contributed their tax dollars our
purchasing power to the city center and
to service available to those in the
inner city quickly declined
unfortunately black families were unable
to access the amenities of the of the
suburbs
Moses purposely built the bridges of
Long Island so low that buses could
never pass the knees in doing so he was
able to keep Long Island pristine a
haven for whites with jobs and beautiful
beaches while trapping black families in
the inner city sadly many of these
divisions remain today
let's take Detroit inner city Detroit is
almost 80 percent black but if you cross
eight Mile Road to the north or the
expressway to the south you find suburbs
that are just one percent black and
there's even a wall its terms
Royce Berlin Wall and it was built in
the 1940s to separate the black
neighborhood from the white one and this
matters it matters to me and it should
matter to all of you it matters because
racial inequality is so deeply embedded
in the u.s. that where you live is a
proxy for your life opportunity social
scientists study the disconnect between
where low income households reside and
where the suitable jobs are located in
cities like Detroit where the black
great segregation is the highest you
also see the highest levels of
disconnect with that job distribution
and the largest black-white income gap
where you live determines where your
children can go to school what food you
can buy what healthcare you can receive
and what public transportation is
available to you so if your race
determines where you live then your race
determines your access to these basic
amenities and this matters for all of us
it's about what is moral and it's about
what it's just but it also has serious
economic consequences one 2013 study
found that a unit increase in a city's
racial segregation led to a 1.5 percent
decrease in the city's economic growth
and in other studies found that greater
segregation is leaked to linked to large
and significant increases in the rates
of violent crimes such as robbery or
aggravated assault this is not
acceptable and it needs to change and
there are things that we all can do
first we need to add amenities to be
still underserved neighborhoods open a
grocery store build a pharmacy invest in
neighborhood gardens entertainment
pace-it spaces or schools we can start
by taking an advantage of underutilized
assets in Cleveland city residents found
an abandoned Kmart building and they
turned it into a recreation center
that's now used by inner-city youth do
you know that there are millions of
square feet of this type of empty floor
place floor space waiting for our
investment
all across the u.s. next we can take a
hard look at our public transportation
system in 1994 the LA bus riders Union
sued the Transit Authority for racially
discriminating against minority groups
in their delivery of public transit the
bus riders won and when la Transit added
hundreds of new buses black ridership
significantly increased and finally we
can implement inclusive housing policies
we need to zone more neighborhoods for
multifamily housing when you invest in a
neighborhood it often leads to
gentrification pushing out the original
tenants as housing prices rise when we
zone for multifamily housing we can keep
prices affordable and protect those most
vulnerable to displacement even as the
value of the neighborhood Rises racial
inequality is a huge issue for this
country yes we need more diversity in
the workforce and yes we need more
equitable treatment of citizens by law
enforcement but I would argue the
Metropolitan equality is the civil
rights issue of the 21st century we need
to understand how our cities were built
how communities were intentionally
marginalized and how those high Gregg
Asians remain today so demand investment
in neighborhoods and demand equitable
public transportation and demand
inclusive affordable housing at Stanford
we strive to change lives and change
organizations and change the world
but let's start by changing the cities
in which we live
[Applause]
[Music]
you